Film Courage: Forgive me, Michael.
Can you explain please quickly what a structural
device is?
It’s a little unclear to me.
Michael Hauge: Sure.
Well, first of all let’s talk about what
structure means.
Structure or plot structure simply means the
sequence of events.
What’s the sequence?
What happens and when does it happen?
Let’s say you’re writing a script and
you want a car chase in it.
Is it going to open the movie?
Is it going to be right at the midpoint?
Is it going to be the climax?
Where does it occur?
That’s a structural question.
So what we’ve been talking about extensively
is my approach to the overall approach to
the story which are the six stages which are
created by those five key turning points.
But within each stage, you still have to be
smart about what the sequence of events would
be.
There are some other structural tools you
can use to help you maximize the emotional
experience for the audience.
Let me give a couple of examples.
One of those would be anticipation.
Keep in mind that when we go to the movies
what we like to do is try and guess what is
going to happen next.
We’re always thinking about “Oh, what
is going to happen?”
And in the movie, you want to create anticipation
in the movie.
And if you go to see JAWS….[laughs] Film
Courage: [Laughs] This is now the third time
during our interview where I think of a movie
[quietly to myself] and you say it!
Michael Hauge: Well, JAWS is such a classic
example of anticipation but it was sort of,
because of the necessity of having a broken
shark, all they really had was a dorsal fin.
But every time we see the dorsal fin, we’re
anticipating “Oh, my God!
Here comes the shark.”
In fact, this has nothing to do with the screenplay
but [composer] John Williams added a lot of
anticipation by creating a theme just for
the shark and now all you have to do is hear
Da…Da…[mimics the shark theme from JAWS].
Everybody in the world knows what those two
notes mean and so that is anticipation.
So we love that because we don’t just want
to sit there bored and only enjoy emotion
when it happens.
We want to think about the conflict to come
because emotion grows out of conflict.
So that is anticipation.
To create that anticipation, there is another
device that is really effective to use and
that is what is known as superior position.
Superior position means telling your reader
or your audience something that some of the
characters in the movie don’t know.
Because that let’s your audience or your
reader anticipate what is going to happen
when the people who don’t know that this
is happening or this exists, don’t know
what I know find out what happened, what I
know.
So the classic example of that would be in
a suspense thriller and then that means you
go to Alfred Hitchcock.
He talked about this all the time.
He had an anecdote he use to say and that
is if you’re shooting a film and two people
are talking sitting across from a desk.
And all at once a bomb that was hidden in
the desk goes off and they’re blown to bits,
you would say (and I’m paraphrasing.
He said it much more elegantly) you’d would
probably squeeze about 60 seconds of emotion
out of that because you’d be shocked and
surprised.
It would be awful and then the audience is
saying “Okay, now what?”
But he says “Supposed the camera cut to
the bomb inside the desk and we know it’s
there.
But the two people at the desk don’t know.
Then you could milk that for 10 minutes because
then you’re thinking “Where is the bomb
squad?
Get out of the room?
Get out of the room?”
And because we know that the bomb is there
but the two people at the desk don’t know.
We have superior position and with that superior
position we can anticipate what’s going
to happen and anticipating the horrible violence
and we don’t want it to happen and now we
are deeply emotionally involved for that conflict
for a for a much longer period of time.
And if you want a more recent example of that
(I’m not going to say too much for the sake
of those who haven’t seen it) but I strongly
recommend everyone see EYE IN THE SKY.
And all I will say about that is for a great
example of superior position, we know what
is going to happen but the girl selling bread
doesn’t know.
And that creates tension that lasts in the
movie for at least (I would guess) 30 to 45
minutes.
Because that whole movie in a way is built
on that superior position and anticipation
of conflict A third example of a structural
device that I recommend highly is a ticking
clock.
That means you always want to built conflict
in your story.
You can exponentially increase the level of
conflict by having whatever you’re trying
to have the hero do, be a race against time.
So again if you have a thriller, it’s like
they’re rushing to stop the killer before
the killer blows up the bomb in the cathedral.
Or there is rushing to stop the bad guy before
the bad guy kills the kidnap victim that they’re
holding hostage.
Okay, so there is a lot of examples of it
in action movies and thrillers and also there
are a lot of examples of it in romantic comedies.
If you look closely at romantic comedies you’ll
see often in the last act of the movie right
before the climax, there will be a scene which
is what I call the race to the wedding.
And you’ll see actually the pace speeds
up.
The hero is rushing to get to the love interest.
So in the movie KNOTTING HILL, she comes to
him and says that famous line “I’m just
a girl standing in front of a boy asking him
to love her and wants to be with him (the
Julia Roberts character) and Will (the Hugh
Grant character) says “I have to refuse
because I can’t have my heart broken again.”
He’s retreating in his identity.
So then he goes to his friends and says “Did
I do the right thing?”
And all his friends say “Yeah, yeah, that’s
right.
It would be a bad idea” and so on.
Until his reflection character Spike comes
into the room and they all tell him he just
broke up with Anna Scott and he looks at Hugh
Grant and says “You daft prick!” because
that’s him holding the hero’s feet to
the fire saying you’re not going with your
truth.
What then happens?
We know and Hugh Grant knows, she’s about
to leave town and he has no idea how to reach
her except she is giving a press conference.
So they all jump in this little car and go
screaming through the streets of London to
get to the hotel where the press conference
is so he can get there and declare his love
for her before she leaves town.
That ticking clock speeds up the momentum,
accelerates the pace, raises the level of
conflict and puts a greater obstacle for the
hero to overcome and that makes the structure
more effective.
Question for the Viewers: What are some great
examples of “Superior Position” and “Ticking
Clocks” in a TV show or Movie?